what's going on guys this is rob and if
you're interested in seeing more videos
like this where i break down trailers
and analyze things from television shows
based on comic books then be sure to
check out my second channel rob explains
and you'll find videos just like this
over there so here's a question what are
my thoughts on the teaser trailer for
Civil War well in this video we're going
to find out so the first part of the
trailer does a pretty good job of
building up suspense for civil war while
returning Bucky Barnes to the landscape
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe now
what's cool about this is that Marvel's
moving into new territory here the
reason why is because in the comics
while Bucky did make his return prior to
civil war with Captain America vol 5
issue number one under Ed Brubaker in
April of 2006 Civil War didn't start
until July of 2006 during which time
Bucky was essentially underground during
the conflict the only appearance he made
that had anything to do with civil war
was following the events conclusion and
the death of Steve Rogers which led to
Bucky undertaking the mantle and Steve's
honor somebody I'd also like to draw
your attention to is the explosion and
what appears to be Germany because this
incident seems out of context I would
argue that this is likely fallout from
the previous actions of Bucky prior to
the events of winter soldier if you
recall during the film Black Widow had
made reference to her only experience
with Bucky and that she had been tasked
with locating and retrieving an unnamed
nuclear scientist from an unnamed
location during her assignment she
encountered Bucky who had been assigned
to kill the scientist something he was
successful in doing by way of shooting
through Romanov where this is largely
speculation I think an argument could be
made here that this may be fallout from
that event regardless of their motives
the police in Germany seemed to have
been tracking Bucky and finally caught
up to him something we noticed when
Bucky fights off several of the police
say which is German for police and makes
his escape the movie also seems to be
taking its permits from civil war itself
in the comics what I mean here is that
prior to this trailer rumors abound as
to what the basis behind the film would
be and whether it would use the idea of
superhuman Registration as the rift
between Tony Stark's Avengers and
Captain America's secret avengers with a
comic saw the introduction of superhuman
Registration as a byproduct of a mutant
named nitro blowing up a portion of
Stamford Connecticut and killing 600
people in the process the incident in
segovia during Avengers 2 and the vast
amount of destruction seems to be the
reason behind the introduction of
registration in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe regardless of the differences
the underlying
similarity is that in the comics society
had grown tired of superheroes acting
with impunity and has decided to impose
accountability for their actions now
whether this means the superheroes will
have to register their identities their
addresses and powers and the same
fashion as in the comics is unknown but
I would argue that this will likely be
the case now for the middle portion of
this trailer between the 44 second mark
and the one minute and 20 seconds of
general Thunderbolt Ross combined with
the footage seems to offer an
alternative to what I had outlined a
second ago with everything seen up to
this point and taking into account the
events of the rest of the trailer I'm
going to go out on a limb here but I'd
like to believe that this is simply set
up for the next phase in the MCU and
what I mean here is that historically
Marvel has usually provided a
well-rounded depiction of a film through
their teasers and their trailers and
usually haven't left much in terms of
hidden features assuming this trailer
follows the same pattern I would surmise
that captain america civil war won't
encompass the entire event in a single
movie and instead will lead into civil
war acting as the next phase of the MCU
on the other hand during an interview
promoting the blu-ray release for
Avengers to Kevin foggy had stated that
civil war will bring an end to the
Captain America trilogy one of this
means as Steve Rogers will die with
Bucky undertaking it's mantle is unknown
but if this is true we may be looking at
the civil war story playing out in a
single film at this point it's really
just too early to know for sure
something else also want to focus on is
the debate between stark and Rogers
light the comic the dichotomy between
the two seems to be the starch sides
with registration while Roger stands
against it as a character who constantly
harps on freedom especially during
captain america 2 and the now-famous
this isn't freedom this is fear line the
disagreement between the two is
essentially a page out of the comics I
would however be curious to see whether
or not start proves themselves to be
both a political and social proponent of
superhuman Registration or if we simply
just signing with it and has no
political input something I was also
really excited about was that we finally
receive our first view of Black Panther
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe now I'm
operating under the assumption that some
kind of back story will be presented
here and that up to this point aside
from the introduction of vibranium
during Captain America one as a nation
of Wakanda during Avengers 2 there has
never been any indication that black
panther
had any contact with any of the heroes
so far this leads me to believe that as
an agency that monitors a globe for
potential threats issue has been
assigned the task of ensuring
registration is enforced it would make
sense that they would comfort atala
especially if Wakanda in the MCU is as
technologically advanced as it is in the
comics on the other hand it could just
be the Black Panthers a turncoat and
then at some point over the course of
the movie he turns against Tony Stark
and decides to fight on the side of
Steve Rogers what's also cool is that we
get to see a chase between Black Panther
and Captain America and a tunnel now the
speed at which Black Panthers running
and the faculty seems to be able to stay
ahead of Rogers indicates that jacala
won't simply exist as a political figure
among the wakandans and instead will
likely have the actual powers of
enhanced strength speed durability and
senses as provided to him by the Panther
God something else you probably noticed
is that James Rhodes appears to have
died and truth this seems to be the
marvel cinematic version of Goliath
dying in the comics for those unaware
Goliath was actually a man named Bill
Foster and was a longtime hero who had
acquired Hank Pym particles and
undertook the name Goliath as he was
only able to grow in size where Bill
Foster had been killed by a clone
version of Thor who was half machine and
whose programming had gone awry and this
instance we don't know if James Rhodes
is actually dead and if he is who it is
that killed him and finally my favorite
part of the trailer comes in the form of
Bucky and Rogers fighting against Tony
Stark to be honest there's really
nothing to be said here except that this
scene is just flat out amazing and
that's all there is to it with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end and let me know down in
the comments section whose side are you
on Captain America or iron man and I
will catch you guys later who's